a senator Avada is proposing a new
provision to a bill that would give
veterinarians the right to prescribe
medical marijuana to dogs
the senator is hoping to add the
provision to a new bill known as SB 372
that will overhaul Nevada's medical
marijuana law I want to move to Nevada
just so that I can say my senator is
named tick Segur blue I like this ticks
Egger blue like them to stone dogs I
know you guys you're both dog people
you're both you know your medical yeah
and you have terrible coma yeah how many
dogs have our gotten stoned at college I
mean let's can't even count could anyone
possibly be against this no but I'm sure
that we'll find them yeah I'm sure
they'll come out of the woodwork yeah
the cat people it's the pro cat
marijuana people are going to be against
yeah yeah so I I don't get it well under
no circumstances the whole entire Jack
Russell Terrier line should be stuck all
the time no offense that's what we
should be done that's nice did a bunch
of dogs and what kind of weed a lot
anyway so I at some level I can
understand I you I'm obviously totally
for legalizing weed altogether and
certainly for medicinal marijuana for
children for anyone that needs it for
any kind of medicinal purpose but I
guess I could understand at some level
somebody that would say they're against
weed recreationally because it's gonna
screw with your mind I don't believe any
of that it's never proven no one no one
commits crime on pot blah blah blah but
what I don't get is how could anyone be
against this for animals right your dogs
not gonna get stoned and go do that bad
stuff that they think people are gonna
do no but really who needs a dog who's
got the munchies
yeah really they're already begging yeah
your dog Stella is a big jumper already
now I've got a begging dog who's also
got the munchies this concerns me a
little bit that's my only fear yeah all
right munchies that's an issue if that
was the doggie treats
not for the people that own
Purina let's go there yeah and the other
issue about this is this is once again
you know this crazy insane idea we have
about hemp and you know marijuana or the
cannabis is you know that you know amp
has been outlawed in this country
because it's related to the cannabis
plant I mean and hemp if you read the
you know people who use hemp and want to
use it for all sorts of things it could
like change change the world anyway can
you so we've talked about this a little
bit on the show but can you just explain
a couple of things that hemp could be
used for me there's a milk of course
which is legal issues great level of
hemp is like you know way higher than
like chicken and beef and which is you
know killing the planet with right takes
it much less energy to produce don't you
know creates gas and all that cattle
rotation it's not as hard on the soil as
a crop rotation fiber I mean it's just
it's a I I'm not a hemp freak yeah but I
read this stuff and I think this is
let's you know if you want to do logic
let's do logic and this is what drives
me crazy about this stuff there's no
science there's no logic they just
ignore it and they're they're you know
marijuana is still deemed as dangerous
as heroin you know as far as it's a
Class A Class A drugs yes and which by
the way a Class A drugs the definition
of a class later says in it in the
definition it says that there's no
medicinal value right right which then
at the same time we have states that are
doing medicinal marijuana so our laws
make no sense yeah absolutely
it's all political and that's what's
right you know it's like let's say in
science I just want science over and
over again well yeah and and just being
practical I mean but let's look at the
positive of this for a second if you own
a dog if you're out there America yeah
I'm stinkbert and you own a dog
immediately go and get that dog a
marijuana license because the next time
you get pulled over
you are a medicinal caregiver and that
weed that's the dog yeah and as an
administrator the dog likes it when a
what they call the thing you take the
joint you reverse and blow it into
someone's mouth shotgun shot
yeah I'm here as the shotgun delivery
suspect that moszer for truffles for
truffles right like I'm taking bong hits
to blow them to the dog because I'm a
caregiver you're being of service yeah
and why stop it dogs like what other
animals can't we get legalized medical
marijuana John giraffes that would be
the goldfish and let's just go across
the board goldfish have memory problems
anywho what do you think stone dogs of
course it should be completely fine
medical marijuana for dogs why would you
not want to help an animal with a
substance that grows from the earth or
that won't stop barking or that one
without marking let us know what you
think in the comments right now